les tags et
pas alors pour ceux qui savent
les anglais savent à dire l'école c'est
nul je ne comprends pas parce que moi
l'école je l'adoré écoles j'avais le
droit de choisir le projet sur lequel je
voulais travailler j'avais le droit
d'organiser mon emploi du temps tout
seul j'allais moi même chercher les
réponses à mes questions auprès de ceux
qui avaient l'expérience
bon ça c'était vrai que là à 2 % du
temps total que j'ai passées à l'école
ouais parce que les 2% en fait du temps
total cela représente les six mois que
j'ai passés ici même dans cet immeuble à
apprendre à entreprendre en gros
apprendre à créer un nouveau métier qui
n'existe pas et c'était cool parce qu'il
fallait être libre pour remonter quelque
chose de nouveau et les 98 % du temps
restant alors eh bien d'après ce que je
me souviens j'étais assis à une table et
je faisais ce qu'on me disait de faire
j'écoutais ce qu'on me disait d'écouté
je dis pas que tout est est
inintéressant mais elle avait des fois
pas étonnant chabot à tetris un tout la
philo je vais passer dessus ou est ce qu
on serait tous aujourd'hui
si pendant toutes nos scolarité on nous
avait donné 100% notre temps et quand on
aurait fait ce qu'on en voulait ou
est-ce qu'on en serait aujourd'hui si on
nous avait appris depuis tout petit à
réaliser nos rêves
ce tag il existerait sûrement pas eh
bien ces écoles où on laisse le temps
aux jeunes tout leur temps pour qu'ils
fassent ce qu'ils veulent
autant de temps qu'ils veulent sans
qu'on leur pose impose jamais aucune
activité
elle existe ce type de pédagogie ça
s'appelle les apprentissages libre et
autonome et c'est dans les écoles
démocratique que ça se passe alors avant
de mettre le pied dans les écoles
démocratique j'aimerais concerne d'abord
ce que sont les apprentissages libre et
autonome vous avez déjà tous fait que
vous avez appris à parler quand vous
avez appris à marcher
tout s'est fait dans le naturel dans
l'informel sont en cours sans notes sans
personne pour vous expliquer comment
est-ce qu'il fallait mettre le pied
droit devant le pied gauche tout ça en
fait ça fait partie des apprentissages
libres et autonomes ce sont des moments
où on apprend sans même s'en apercevoir
un petit peu comme on ne s'aperçoit pas
qu'on respire en fait donc voilà on va
commencer à rentrer dans les écoles
démocratique et première fois que je
rentrais dans je me suis dit waouh ça
ressemble pas du tout à une école alors
ok il y avait des tableaux des stylos
des tables de chaises mais il y avait
aussi des canapés des poufs une guitare
un piano playstation et toute la série
des final fantasy en accès libre
tout le temps il y avait du monde de
tout âge les enfants avec des ados des
ados avec des adultes et adultes avec
des enfants tous mélanger tous respectés
en fait imaginez vous plutôt une école
démocratique comme une maison où chacun
fait sa vie interagit avec tout le monde
où chacun en fait utilise son temps
comme bon lui semble avec n'importe
quelles ressources mises à sa
disposition
et alors quand on arrive dedans on se
demande mais comment ça se fait que ce
soit pas le bazar permanent un lieu avec
que des enfants libres de faire ce
qu'ils ont envie de faire
eh bien ils ont très rapidement compris
le principe fondamental de la liberté la
liberté s'arrête là où commence celle de
l'autre
dès lors qu'on vit à plusieurs on a
besoin de se mettre d'accord sur ce
qu'on a le droit de pas ou faire en
rapport avec ce que l'autre se permet ou
pas d'accepter alors on établit des
règles établies des lois frappé mal
c'est enfin pelo c'est mal on est tous
d'accord et pas besoin de s'accorder
longtemps collectivement là dessus et
quand il s'agit de faire une loi sur
disons l'aménagement du local
ces massacres
eu des tensions il faut qu'on sache
comment on se met d'accord faut qu'on
trouve un moyen pour se dire ok qu'est
ce qu'il va décider comment est-ce qu'on
va l'emporter qui va qui va choisir
alors on choisit un système de
gouvernance du système de gouvernance
démocratique où chaque voix a le même
poids du fondateur
asiana sept ans qui vient d'arriver le
mois dernier donc ce système là qui
régule la vie collective
c'est plus qu'un choix en fait c'est une
nécessité puisque rappelez vous on parle
d apprentissage libre et autonome
l'enfant est maître de son apprentissage
on doit lui laisser le pouvoir de
façonner son école à son image c'est là
que l'égalité s'installe entre chaque
membre adulte enfant de chacun comprend
que le le règlement intérieur est la
seule autorité qui règne à l'école
démocratique
chacun comprend que on se doit de le
respecter
si on veut continuer à être libre au
sein de ce collectif
c'est ce cadre là en fait qui détermine
qui délimite notre liberté est donc très
bien ces écoles où les enfants
apprennent tout seul gère tout tout seul
il sert à quoi l'adulte va pas faire le
ménage à coeur l'adulte ici il sert
surtout à répondre aux questions à
répondre aux besoins exprimés l'enfant
il va jamais allé plus loin que la
demande exprimée et ça c'est super
important
c'est super important parce que ça va
permettre aux jeunes de développer son
autonomie sa créativité et son esprit
critique
admettons qu'un jeune viennent demander
une question et il obtient une réponse
est ce que je suis satisfait de ma
réponse
si oui très bien j'ai eu ce que je
voulais je vais continuer à faire
d'autres activités qui me plaisent et
puis d'autres questions va arriver
ensuite
sinon et bien je
chalach formulée je cherche à l'art
précisé pour obtenir finalement
l'information dont j'avais besoin
par contre ce que je ne veux pas en tant
qu'enfant ces écoutes étaient gentils
d'explication superflu que je ne t'ai
jamais demandé parce que juste aime bien
expliquer les choses
je pense à je pense à ma petite cousine
qui a il ya six ans qui est ce qu'il ya
six ans elle me demandait pourquoi les
planètes elle tourne autour du soleil
les planètes et le temps de retour du
soleil parce que et une certaine force
qui les attire ça s'appelle la
gravitation la gravitation ça fait
partie d'une des quatre forces
fondamentales de l'univers la force et
le mot est faible et arrête toi là tu as
juste demandé pourquoi les planètes
tournent autour du soleil dont tu lui
réponds la gravitation
si elle veut aller plus loin il ira
chercher elle-même où elle te posera la
question encore d'aller plus loin ou pas
le but avec ce genre de choses là pas du
tout ce que je voulais dire oublier
jeudi injuste c'est bien beau de
réfléchir aux planètes comment elle
tourne autour du soleil
mais quand est ce que cette jeune
cousine va-t-elle apprendre à calculer
combien elles sont quand est-ce qu'elle
va apprendre à lire leur nom écrire leur
nom
c'est important on est tous d'accord
avec ça la lecture l'écriture le calcul
comment est ce qu'un jeune peut
apprendre tout seul dans une école
démocratique
comment le faire ayant pour être honnête
j'en sais rien j'en sais rien je sais
juste que que le jeune quand il va
sortir il va mettre un pied dans la rue
il va être entouré de chiffres et de
lettres pour lui il s'agira forcément
tôt ou tard il sera donc forcément tôt
tartan de les assimiler pour pouvoir les
manipuler pour pouvoir continuer à
échanger avec tous les gens autour de
nous il ya un exemple dont j'aime bien
parler c'est celui de kim elle a 8 ans
elle est jamais allé à l'école
on lui a jamais appris à lire on lui a
jamais écrit jamais appris à écrire ni à
calculer et pourtant un beau jour ses
parents s'aperçoivent qu'elle sait le
faire comment il a fait en fait elle a
appris à lire à écrire et raconter comme
elle a appris à marcher comme elle a
appris à parler naturellement dans
l'informel sans effort c'est à force de
curiosité d'exploration de
questionnements que la curiosité
naturelle de l'enfant reprend le dessus
et fait des merveilles
alors ces merveilles qu'est ce que c'est
et bien c'est thomas 15 ans qui fait des
plats de chefs chaque semaine c'est
angeline 12 ans qui fait des maths tout
seul pour intégrer la police judiciaire
c'est ce groupe d'ados la de 13 14 ans
qui ensemble cliquer sur des prods avec
leurs propres textes
alors pour pour les anciens cliquez sur
des prod ça veut dire faire du rap et
pour les plus anciens le rap c'est un
style de musique
ces merveilles c'est tous ces jeunes qui
savent où est ce qu'ils vont parce
qu'ils ont eu le temps de savoir où est
ce qu'ils voulaient aller qui récupère
qui atteignent qui atteignent tout les
ai tous les ai toutes les universités et
les métiers qu'ils veulent parce qu'ils
savent comment y accéder parce qu'ils
ont pris le temps d'y réfléchir mais pas
longtemps j'ai entendu un
yahia dos il a dit un truc du genre à
ses parents si tu veux le meilleur pour
moi
arrête de me dire ce qui est bon pour
moi cette phrase elle est puissante et
veut tout dire je veux dire que le jeune
il a compris qu'il peut se faire
confiance elle veut dire que le jeune il
arrive à assumer ses choix de vie
hillary m'a il arrive à s'affranchir de
la pression de ses parents de la
pression sociale
il arrive à faire confiance en son
avenir
chaque enfant chaque enfoncé il
deviendra adulte un jour alors
donnons-lui le temps
donnons-lui 100% du temps pour qu'il
devienne qu'il a vraiment envie d'être
je me demande pourquoi est ce que les
écoles elle n'encourage pas à exprimer
leur curiosité
je me demande pourquoi les écoles elles
ne les emmène pas sur le terrain
d'exploration le leur peut-être parce
que on a peur on a peur qu'ils ne
trouvent pas leur voix alors on imagine
des programmes qui les rendraient e
meilleur sans savoir si ce serait bon
pour eux les jeunes ils savent déjà bien
avant enfin ils sauront avant nous de
quoi le futur sera fait le monde de
demain il est déjà eu alors à nous
d'être uniquement présents pour veiller
sur eux et servir de miroir sur lequel
leurs actions leurs idées leurs destins
peuvent rebondir et peut-être qu'un jour
bas on trouvera dans les rues ce tag là
[Applaudissements]